Have you ever, you know, found
yourself in the middle of some
big societal upheaval, maybe a
widespread fear or something,
and felt that really deep,
almost gut feeling like, who did
this?
Who's to blame?
Oh definitely that urge to point
a finger.
Exactly.
And it feels like such an
ancient question, right?
Like back when the sky suddenly
went dark or a plague hit and
people were terrified, asking
who angered the gods who did
this to us?
Yeah, that a primal need for an
answer for A cause.
Well, today we're doing a really
deep dive into an argument that
suggests that ancient impulse.
It hasn't really gone away in
our, you know, modern rational
world.
It's just found new targets,
often in pretty unexpected ways.
That's right.
The source material we're
looking at today, it's it takes
us on quite a journey.
It's this exploration called the
Trump shaped hole.
And it goes way beyond the usual
political talk.
It digs into how for some
people, well, a very public
figure is could have
accidentally filled this really
profound void, becoming almost
like a like the source calls it
a trickster God in the modern.
Mind a trickster God?
OK, Yeah.
So we're going to look at this
not, you know, not through
policy debates or who's right or
wrong politically, but by trying
to understand these really deep
underlying human patterns, that
sort of psychological stuff that
this source brings out so
vividly.
So our mission here, it's really
important to stay upfront.
This isn't about taking sides
politically, definitely not
dissecting policies.
It's about understanding this
really profound argument that
the source mix right, how these
powerful ancient human impulses
like needing a scapegoat,
needing someone to blame,
needing to fill that, you know
that fundamental God shaped hole
inside us, how they show up
today and.
Often unintentionally, right?
Yeah, that's a key.
Part exactly, completely
unintentionally, often we're
sort of unpacking the idea that
even now, in what feels like a
really secular, advanced stage,
these super deep seated human
responses to fear, to chaos, to
things we just can't explain,
they're still incredibly
powerful.
And you know, to help us
navigate this, the sources, they
bring in some really surprising
concepts while we talk about
things like Eclipse Sphere,
these mythological trickster
gods, the legends of golems.
Golems.
Wow.
Yeah, and even some more
esoteric ideas like tulpas and
egregore's.
OK, you lost me a bit there,
tulpas.
We'll get into them, yeah.
But the point is, they're not
just like interesting old ideas.
The source uses them directly to
try and understand how people
today perceive this public
figure.
Right.
So we'll explore all this
impartially, just focusing on
the arguments the source
presents, trying to get the
mechanics of these ideas, you
know, not pushing any political
view.
It's about the human story
underneath.
OK, let's start with that first
concept, then this Eclipse fear
and what the source calls the
primal question.
The basic idea here, it's it's
really compelling.
It is that since like forever,
humans have reacted to big
natural disasters, the sun
vanishing, plagues, droughts,
huge floods with this one
desperate question.
Who did this?
Who made the gods mad?
Who do we blame?
It's that immediate search for
agency, for responsibility, even
in the face of, you know, raw
nature.
Yeah, it echoes through like
every ancient culture you can
think of.
It seems universal.
And what the source finds really
insightful is how modern
Americans, you know, despite all
our science, our belief that
we're beyond that kind of
thinking.
We think we're so rational.
Right.
We think we've outgrown it, but
the source argues we still have
this raw animal dread, just just
under the surface of all our
sophisticated explanations.
So underneath the policy talk
and the data.
Exactly.
We talked about policy failures,
political decisions, economic
data to explain things going
wrong.
But, you know, scratch that
veneer and that same eclipse
fear that terrified our
ancestors.
It's still there.
It's still kind of demands a
face, a single person or thing
to pin the blame on.
Wow.
It's like the mind trying to
force order onto chaos.
That's a good way to put it.
It's trying to make the
incomprehensible feel somehow
manageable by giving it a name.
OK, this is where it gets, like
really concrete, because the
source gives this powerful,
almost visceral example that
awful Hill Country flood in
Texas.
Oh yeah, that was devastating.
Imagine it, the slow storm just
sitting over those hills and
then bam a 30 foot wall of water
just breaks through middle of
the night drowns a Christian
camp.
Just horrifying.
And the source points out, the
National Weather Service
apparently was stretched thin.
Budget cuts, you know the story.
They tried to warn people.
Right.
And some listen, some didn't.
Maybe they didn't trust the
warnings anymore.
Who knows?
Lots of factors.
But here's the kicker, According
to the source, despite all
these, you know, rational,
complex reasons for the tragedy,
budget cuts, individual choices,
the weather itself, the
immediate talk, the the
primitive drum beat, as the
source calls it.
What was it?
It turned, almost instantly to
one single explanation.
Trump did this.
Seriously, like he personally
caused the flood?
Well, the source says the way it
was covered, the way people
talked about it, made it sound
that simple, that direct.
Trump made the flood.
Trump killed those kids.
And the source argues, look,
that's not policy analysis.
That is pure ancient scapegoat
logic.
Wow, just finding one person to
blame for this massive, complex
natural disaster.
Exactly.
It's that ancient urge to pin
the blame for the uncontrollable
onto 1 figure, as if just seeing
the name could somehow contain
the terror.
You know, so the source is
basically saying it's like we're
dragging, I don't know, but Al
or Malak or raw these the
ancient gods of chaos and
floods.
Yeah, or the Old Testament God
of plagues.
Right.
Dragging them into a modern
press conference, but just
giving them like, like a
contemporary face.
It seems almost unbelievable
that we're still wired that way.
That's precisely the parallel
the source draws.
It's stark.
It shows how these ancient blame
patterns hang on even when we
dress them up in modern language
and apply them to political
figures.
But.
Why?
What's the psychological driver
there?
Well, think about it.
When you're faced with
overwhelming chaos, a natural
disaster, an economic collapse,
A pandemic, the human mind
really, really struggles with
randomness.
It craves order.
And often the easiest way to
impose order is to find a
villain, a single point of
failure where you can project
all the fear, the grief, the
confusion.
It gives the chaos a face.
Exactly.
It makes the uncontrollable
feel, paradoxically, a bit more
manageable because now there's
something concrete to be angry
at, to fight against.
It's a coping mechanism, I mean,
even if it's a destructive one,
because the alternative, just
pure meaningless chaos, is
frankly terrifying for most
people.
That is unsettling, that this
ancient fear is still like
beating away under all our
modern layers.
And that leads us to this other
concept.
The source brings the secular
priesthood and their unseen
gods.
Right, the source uses this
term, so-called secular rational
class describes them as this
coastal priesthood of academia,
media and hyper modern
humanists.
A priest.
Yeah, and the point is, they
strongly insist there's no
spirit realm, no demon in the
whirlwind, no trickster sun God.
They're adamant they've moved
past all.
That they're rationalists.
Supposedly, yeah.
And yet the source argues the
way they talk about this
specific figure, the one they
blame for the flood and, you
know, everything else, they talk
about him as if he is exactly
that kind of mythic evil.
It's this really stark
contradiction.
So they reject the idea, but act
as if it's true.
That's the argument.
Consciously, they reject the
spiritual or mythological Yeah,
about their language, their
behavior and what discussing
him.
It takes on this almost like
religious intensity.
And the source compares them to
the Pharisees.
It does now for anyone
listening.
The Pharisees were, you know, an
ancient Jewish sect known for
being really strict about
religious laws, especially
purity rules.
They were obsessed with who was
clean and unclean.
The source argues that in a
modern way, certain secular
groups, this coastal priesthood,
they do something similar.
They might reject traditional
religion, but they enforce their
own set of moral tests, purity
codes, and they're constantly
defining who's clean or unclean
based on their own ideology.
So it's like a secular version
of drawing moral lines in the
sand, creating an US versus
them.
Exactly like a kind of secular
moral policing.
It mirrors those ancient
religious structures, even
though they're not talking about
God or scriptures explicitly.
So it's less about divine law
and more about like social or
ideological purity.
Who holds the right beliefs uses
the right labels?
That seems to be the idea.
It suggests.
Maybe there's this universal
human need for some kind of
ritual, some moral framework,
some way to define us and them.
Even if we consciously try to
get rid of it.
Yeah, even if we reject the old
forms, that need finds new ways
to express itself.
Maybe unconsciously.
It's like the human psyche just
has to create these systems of
meaning and blame.
If the old ways of dealing with
chaos are gone, the underlying
mental machinery just finds new
stuff to work with.
OK, so if that ancient eclipse
sphere makes us look for a
scapegoat, what happens when the
things that used to give us
meaning, you know, the things
that helped us cope with chaos,
start to fade away?
Now you're getting to the God
shaped whole.
Right.
I've heard that phrase
traditionally.
It's like this empty space
inside us that needs something
bigger than ourselves, right?
Like God or a law or some
transcendent purpose?
Exactly.
And for centuries that provided
real comfort, real meaning.
When terrible things happened.
A child dying in a flood, Crops
failing.
It wasn't just seen as random
awfulness.
How does it seem?
It was often framed as like a
mystery wrapped in mercy, or
maybe a test from God.
There was a sense of a larger
divine plan, even in suffering.
It helped people find solace,
find a spiritual reason for the
inexplicable.
It offered a way to handle that
existential dread.
But the source argues this
modern secular priesthood, they
declared themselves sort of
above it.
Yeah, they said, you know, we
don't need a cosmic father or
groom beyond the veil.
They kind of ridiculed people of
faith for holding on to those
beliefs.
And then according to the
source, they tried to fill that
God shaped hole with different.
Thing totally different things.
Things like credentials, moral
status, hashtags, identity
labels, purity tests.
They built, as the source puts
it, new tabernacles of
rationalism.
Hashtags and credentials instead
of faith.
What are the implications of
that of try and fill that hole
with with that stuff?
Well, the source argues, the big
problem was they didn't realize
that old animal wiring was still
buried underneath.
The hole didn't go away.
Nature hates a vacuum, right?
Exactly.
And the source suggests that
unlike, say, a religious
framework which could offer
solace for deep suffering, these
modern intellectual things, they
mostly offered intellectual
comfort, Meaning they didn't
really touch the raw emotional
pain, the existential dread that
comes with real chaos, real
loss.
Like what happens when your
moral status or your Twitter
profile can't explain why a
flood destroyed your home or why
someone you love died suddenly?
The intellectual answers don't
cut it.
They just crumble, and that
leaves that primal need for
meaning, or for a face to blame,
or for some kind of explanation.
Still hungry, still looking to
be filled by something.
So denying the need or trying to
fill it with the wrong things
leaves this void.
Yeah, a void that's just waiting
for something else to rush in,
often in ways you really didn't
intend.
So because that God shaped hole
was still there, maybe denied or
just poorly filled, the source
says fear took a shape and that
shape became what it calls the
trickster.
Yes, the cosmic scapegoat, to be
cursed for every unspeakable
thing they cannot control.
This is where that old fear
meets that modern void.
Now this is really important.
You said the source emphasizes
this trickster isn't the actual
man himself.
Absolutely crucial.
It's not the lumpy, mortal
reality of an aging real estate
loudmouth from Queens, as the
source vividly puts it.
OK, ha ha ha.
Vivid indeed.
Instead, it's the enormous
mythic projection that lives
rent free in their heads.
It's a psychological construct,
right?
An entity basically fueled by
intense emotion, by deep fear,
and that relentless need to
blame someone.
And the source describes this
trickster almost like a
mythological figure.
Totally with these like mythic
attributes, gold toilets and
tiny hands.
But WHO somehow manipulates
sleds, suicides, epidemics,
Ukraine, Gaza, Texas, and the
minds of every citizen too
stupid to resist him?
It's this larger than life
embodiment of everything they
fear and can't control, all
condensed into one single form.
You know what really strikes me
here is how easily we can all
fall into that kind of thinking.
Life throws incredibly complex
problems at us, global
pandemics, wars, local
disasters.
And the mind just naturally
wants a simple answer, a single
'cause.
It's overwhelming otherwise.
Right.
And this trickster figure, it
provides that simple, even if
it's totally mythic explanation.
It's a way to cope, I guess, a
way to make sense of things that
don't make sense, even if it
means getting fixated in a maybe
unhealthy way.
It's so much easier
psychologically to have one
single villain to blame for
everything, rather than trying
to untangle the messy,
complicated, often random
reality of how things actually
happen.
It gives you a target.
A target for all the fear and
rage and that offers this
illusion maybe of control in
situations where you feel
totally powerless.
And this becomes especially
powerful, the source argues,
when those traditional sources
of comfort and meaning, like
faith or community, have been
sort of pushed aside, leaving
that basic human need unmet and
just open for this kind of
intense projection.
OK, let's dig a bit deeper into
this trickster God idea itself.
Because the source isn't just
using it casually.
It draws parallels to actual
mythic figures, right?
Like Loki or Coyote or Nancy the
Spider.
Exactly.
These figures from different
mythologies, Norse, Native
American, West African.
They're known for being chaotic,
unpredictable, sometimes funny,
sometimes genuinely destructive.
The existing stories partly to
explain why the world isn't
always fair or logical, why bad
things happen OK.
And the source argues that for
some people, this particular
public figure functions in
exactly that mythological role.
He becomes the single
unpredictable villain who seems
to explain everything bad, the
ultimate source of chaos in
their worldview.
It's a pretty disturbing way to
see someone.
The source uses that metaphor,
the Forrest Gump of their
apocalypse, but flipped.
Yeah, I thought that was really
striking.
So instead of Forrest Gump just
accidentally being present at
every big event.
Right.
Cluelessly witnessing history.
This figure is seen as the
opposite, as the nefarious
hidden 'cause they see lurking
behind every photo, every flood,
every border crisis, every
whispered conspiracy.
Wow, that really shows the depth
of the projection, doesn't it?
Seeing him as the root cause of
literally everything wrong.
That's like a psychological
shortcut.
It connects all these different
anxieties, political, social,
personal, into one single
coherent, even if it's paranoid
story.
And the source points out, this
pattern of blame becomes almost
like a ritual, A catechism that
never updates.
Yeah, that's a key point.
They blamed him for, say,
alleged Russia collusion.
But then, the source notes, when
evidence pointed elsewhere,
maybe towards another political
camp, the story didn't really
change the the blame just
shifted or intensified.
It stuck to him.
It stuck.
They blamed him for Epstein, for
the pandemic, for that storm
that hit the camp, the source
says.
The scapegoat logic sticks
because the old fear needs it.
It becomes less about the actual
facts and more about satisfying
that deep, persistent
psychological need for one
single bad guy to carry the
weight of everything that feels
wrong.
So the narrative becomes almost
immune to contradictory
information.
That's what seems to happen.
The need for the villain is so
strong it can override A
rational updating of the story
based on new facts.
And that really reinforces the
idea that this is less about the
man himself and more about the
psychological hole he's filling
for those doing the projecting.
It makes it feel more like
ancient myth making than modern
analysis.
Exactly that fixed blame,
regardless of evidence, is what
makes it so similar to those old
rituals and myths.
Speaking of narratives, this
leads to another really poignant
idea in the source, this concept
of the ruined redemption arc.
Ah.
Yes, this is fascinating.
The source suggests that some
people, maybe whole groups,
poured enormous psychic energy
into creating this story, this
narrative arc that they thought
would, like, redeem their
history, secure their place in
the story of American progress.
Yeah, like building this great
civil rights quilt, the source
calls it through protests,
writing think pieces, viral
posts, all of it contributing to
this narrative.
And this connects to what a need
for a grand story.
A very human need for a story of
progress, of good triumphing
over evil, where you personally
play a heroic part.
The source mentions people who
are descendants of, say, a Selma
marcher or an Auschwitz
Liberator or someone who fought
for the pill.
Or even people who just deeply
identify with those figures who
believe they would have done the
same.
Right.
And their design fire, according
to the source, is to find that
villain, that monster to defeat,
to keep the redemption arc
alive.
It's not just about winning an
election.
It's about maintaining their
sense of moral purpose, their
historical importance, their
identity tied to this ongoing
story of American progress.
It's about their place in that
heroic story.
Exactly.
Securing their legacy?
Almost, but.
Then the source says the
trickster Gollum ruined the
story he just trampled.
It, yeah, trampled the final
scene, hijacked all that moral
momentum, all that energy they
built up.
The source uses this great image
like a spacecraft slingshotting
around a planet's gravity well
and hurled it back at them.
Wow, so all that effort aimed at
creating this like post racial
post binary paradise.
Yeah, this moon shot to make
America the most just
progressive place imaginable.
Yeah, it just got absorbed and
deflected by this one.
Figures lurching gate, basically
throwing the whole grand
narrative off the rails.
The source describes this real
sense of frustration, almost
betrayal.
Deep frustration.
They wanted to be the final
liberators, the ones who ushered
in the ultimate era of justice,
defeated the fascist inside the
American genome.
But the tricksters grotesque
grin tramples the scene.
And they're shouting cut, cut,
but he won't cooperate.
Exactly.
The golem won't cooperate, and
that illustrates this profound
psychological shock when a story
you deeply believe in, a story
tied to your identity and
purpose, just gets fundamentally
disrupted by reality.
It's more than just political
defeat, then, it's a crisis of
meaning.
A loss of identity tied to that
story.
It's like imagine pouring your
soul into building this
incredible masterpiece, your
life's work, and then someone
just comes along and throws
paint all over it, completely
disregarding your vision.
That's a powerful metaphor, that
feeling of having your whole
narrative just overturned.
It explains why the reaction can
be so intense maybe.
Absolutely.
Our sense of who we are is often
tangled up in the stories we
tell about the world and our
role in it.
When someone comes along who
just doesn't fit the script, who
disrupts the expected hero
villain dynamic, it can feel
like an existential threat.
So people double down on the
original story.
Or try desperately to force
reality back into that
framework, even when it doesn't
fit.
That's why the reactions can be
so visceral, so personal, even
for people not directly involved
in politics.
This leads us to a really
critical part of the analysis.
These two very different ways of
seeing the same figure, like 2
separate mythologies running at
the same time.
Exactly.
So first, for his opponents, the
source says he started off just
like renting space in their
heads.
An annoyance.
Yeah, maybe just an irritation
initially, but then the source
uses this analogy.
Like bronchitis that starts in
the sinuses and drips down into
your lungs, this trickster idea
migrated from mind to heart.
It became something deeper, more
pervasive.
And this is where those esoteric
terms come in.
Tulpa and egregore.
Right.
And they're kind of key to
understanding this part of the
argument.
Think about the sheer amount of
collective mental and emotional
energy focused on one person.
A tulpa in Tibetan mysticism is
basically a thought form, an
entity that theoretically can be
created just through intense
mental focus and belief by a
group of people.
Like a shared hallucination,
almost.
Kind of, yeah.
Something that takes on a life
of its own in the collective
mind and in egregore is a
similar older occult idea.
It's a collective psychic entity
sustained by a group's shared
emotions, beliefs, maybe even
rituals.
So the source is arguing this
trickster isn't just a
projection, it's become like a
living psychic entity.
An accidental tulpa or egregore?
Yeah, fueled by all the fear,
all the blame, all the constant
attention poured into it.
Wow, so they've inadvertently Co
created this thing they despise
and keep feeding it with their
own emotions?
That's incredibly unsettling.
That's exactly the argument.
The source describes them again
vividly as becoming accidental
Jesus freaks, accidental sun
worshippers chanting in an
orange disk named Sol.
Sol like the sun.
Right.
Turning their heads into
pulpits, their hearts into
altars, their rage into a cosmic
tulpa they keep alive with every
new hashtag and effigy.
It's this image of unconscious
devotion driven by dread, not
admiration.
It really makes you think about
where you put your own focus,
doesn't it?
How much energy you give to
things you oppose.
Definitely.
Could we be inadvertently making
things larger than life in our
own heads, letting them consume
our energy?
The source stresses this was
inadvertent, a consequence of
that unchecked fear and that
unfilled void.
OK, so that's the trickster God
view.
Now, completely contrasting
that, how do his supporters, the
villagers as the source calls
them, see him?
As a Gollum.
A Gollum.
OK, remind us what that is
again.
So in Jewish folklore, a Gollum
is usually made of clay or mud,
brought to life by mystical
means, typically to protect a
community from attack.
It's strong, often huge, but
importantly, usually mute.
And it has a specific a.
Specific job, and this is
crucial.
When the job is done or if it
goes rogue, it could be
deactivated, turned back into
lifeless clay.
It's a protector, but a
temporary functional 1.
So the source applies that to
how supporters see Trump.
Exactly.
For them, he's their flawed
champion.
Not a God, not a king, just a
stand in to guard the garden
while the storms rage.
He's seen as this crude
disposable protector.
Disposable.
That's the keyword there, isn't
it?
Absolutely central to the golem
idea, the source says very
clearly.
When he cracks, they'll grind
him back to dust and walk away
and.
So it's not religious devotion
at all, It's pragmatic,
utilitarian almost.
Utterly pragmatic, and this
highlights the huge difference,
right?
For opponents, he's this all
consuming, almost supernatural
force, this trickster God or
tulpa they can't escape.
For supporters, he's a tool, a
means to an end, a temporary
shield against things they fear.
Like the coastal priesthood's
acid rain, as the source puts
it.
A brute force answer A.
Brute force answer to what they
see as an existential threat.
The implications are huge.
They show completely different
psychological needs being met
and totally different ideas
about what happens next.
Especially when he's eventually
off the stage.
It's like people are living in
completely different
mythological universes while
looking at the exact same
person.
Based on their own fears and
needs, yeah.
Which brings us to this idea of
Bad Religion and how this whole
cycle keeps going.
The source talks about the
ritual of burning effigies.
Right, an ancient practice
making a doll or figure of
someone you see as a threat and
then symbolically destroying it
to to, you know, banish the
evil, cleanse the community.
And the source connects this
directly to modern stuff.
Directly, it argues that when
people burn Trump in effigy over
and over, whether it's actual
effigies or giant baby blimps,
pinatas, voodoo dolls, maybe
even just relentless online
attacks, they are often, without
realizing it, repeating this
ancient ritual.
An unconscious attempt at
exorcism.
Pretty much an act loaded with
his deep historical and
psychological meaning, even if
the people doing it have no clue
about the ancient roots or what
it really does psychologically.
But here's the twist, right?
The source says it doesn't
actually banish him.
That's the crucial
counterintuitive point.
The intent is to banish, but the
result, ironically, can be to
keep him alive in the mind
instead.
Because the very act of symbolic
destruction, that intense focus,
it actually fuels the tulpa or
egregore.
It feeds the psychic energy of
the projection.
You're feeding the monster
you're trying to slay.
That's the argument, and that's
what the source means by Bad
Religion.
It's not about criticizing any
specific faith.
It's about this unconscious
ritualistic behavior that looks
like rational political action
but functions like superstition.
Like adopting rituals of blame
and symbolic destruction without
understanding their real
psychological kickback.
Exactly.
Yeah, Blaming, cursing, burning
effigies becomes a Bad Religion
when people don't see they're
accidentally feeding the very
fears they claim to about Crone.
Yeah, it's this self
perpetuating cycle.
The intense opposition
ironically makes the target more
powerful, more present in the
minds of those who hate him
most.
Turning a mortal man into this
inescapable mental entity.
Yeah.
So wrapping this all together
then the core argument is if it
floods like a God, punishes like
a God and devours like a God,
it's a God.
But this God like power, it's
not for the supporters, right?
Not for the villagers who see
him as the clay golem.
No, the source is very clear
that mythic power, that God like
stature, is precisely for the
ones who hate him so completely
that they can't stop burning the
effigy.
They are the ones, in this view,
who are inadvertently giving him
that mythic power to their
non-stop focus, their constant
blame, their ritual opposition.
They see him as this cosmic
villain, the reason for
everything bad.
And in doing so, they grant him
this terrifying omnipresence
inside their own heads.
They've essentially filled their
own God shaped hole with this
figure of absolute dread.
And that has a cost, an unseen
cost a.
Huge cost, the source says.
They think they're saving
themselves, but they're the ones
who keep the fire fed.
It's about the self-inflicted
burden of carrying that much
intense, all consuming
opposition, believing you're
fighting something external
while actually internalizing and
sustaining it.
Which leads to that final,
really striking statement.
For this part.
The Trump shaped hole isn't just
in their heads anymore.
It migrated straight into the
hollow place in their chest
where something greater used to
live.
Yeah, it's a powerful, almost
tragic image of replacement.
That void, that space that may
be used to hold spiritual
meaning or community connection,
or just a sense of purpose
beyond the self.
It's now occupied by this figure
of intense dread and opposition.
It shows what can happen when
that basic human need for
meaning gets denied or goes
unmet, doesn't it?
When hope or faith leave a
space, fear and obsession can
just rush right in to fill it
up.
It's a stark warning about those
unintended consequences.
OK, so we've really covered a
lot of ground in this deep dive
into the Trump shaped hole.
We started way back with Ancient
Eclipse.
Fear that primal need to blame
someone when chaos hits.
Yeah, and how that impulse seems
to persist, showing up in modern
society.
Right, filling that God shaped
hole that maybe some people
tried to ignore or fill with
purely intellectual stuff.
And for his opponents this
figure became a trickster God.
This accidental tulpa or
egregore?
Fueled by their own fear, blame,
and these rituals of Bad
Religion that ironically keep
the projection alive.
While in complete contrast, his
supporters see him as a Gollum
powerful, flawed, but ultimately
A disposable tool.
A pragmatic protector out of
God.
These two totally different
mythologies existing side by
side, shaping everything.
It's a story about politics,
sure, but really it's about the
enduring strangeness and power
of the human psyche, isn't it?
Absolutely.
So we want to leave you, the
listener, with a final thought
to chew on.
It builds on a question someone
asked the author of the source
material.
Linda, go in.
What happens when he's no longer
here?
That's the big question, isn't
it?
If this Trump shaped hole really
is about a deeper human need for
a scapegoat, for a figure to
fill a void in a chaotic world,
what happens to that hole when
the current Trickster Got or
Gollum isn't the main focus
anymore?
Does the hole just vanish?
Do we all suddenly become
perfectly rational?
Or does humanity, with its
persistent eclipse fear and that
still unaddressed God shaped,
just find or maybe even create a
new figure, a new villain, a new
champion to project all those
collective fears and needs onto?
Does the cycle just start over
with a different face?
That's the provocative question
the Source leaves us with, and
it invites you to think not just
about society, but about your
own holes.
How do you fill them
consciously?
Unconsciously.
Are we really as rational as we
like to think?
Or are these ancient fears,
these ancient needs, still
pulling the strings in ways we
don't even realize?
Something to think about.